♪ ♪
AFTER A WEEK HIGHLIGHTED BY
DEMOCRATIC DEBATES,
PRESIDENT TRUMP FINALLY GETTING
HIS CHANCE TO RESPOND, THE
PRESIDENT NOT HOLDING BACK AT A
RALLY IN OHIO BY UNLEASHING ON
HIS 2020 RIVALS, SINGLING OUT
ELIZABETH WARREN AND JOE BIDEN
WILL ALSO GOING AFTER THEIR
PARTY'S PROGRESSIVE POLICIES.
>> WHILE REPUBLICANS ARE WORKING
EVERY DAY TO BUILD UP OUR
COUNTRY, THE RAGE FILLED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS TRYING TO
TEAR AMERICA APART.
THE GREAT POCAHONTAS WHO IS NOW
LYING AND CHEATING HER WAY TO
THE PRESIDENCY IF POSSIBLE, SHE
SAID SHE WAS INDIAN AND I SAID
THAT I HAVE A MORE INDIAN BLOOD
THAN SHE DOES, AND I HAVE NONE,
I'M SORRY.
FOR THE LAST 20 YEARS, CHINA HAS
TAKEN HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OUT OF OUR
COUNTRY, THEY WOULD LOVE TO SEE
A GUY LIKE SLEEPY JOE BIDEN WHO
HAS NO CLUE WHAT HE'S DOING.
THEY WOULD SAY TO SLEEPY JOE,
SIR, JUST SIGN RIGHT THERE.
OH, OKAY.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT NOT
BACKING DOWN IN THE BATTLE OVER
BALTIMORE.
>> NO ONE HAS PAID A HIGHER
PRICE FOR THE FAR LEFT'S
DESTRUCTIVE AGENDA THAN
AMERICANS LIVING IN OUR NATION'S
INNER CITIES, WE SPEND BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS AND BILLIONS FOR
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS AND
ITS STOLEN MONEY AND ITS WASTED
MONEY AND IT'S A SHAME.
THE CONDITIONS IN NANCY PELOSI'S
ONCE GREAT CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
ARE DEPLORABLE, THEY ARE
DEPLORABLE.
LOOK AT LOS ANGELES, WITH THE
TENTS AND THE HORRIBLE,
HORRIBLE, DISGUSTING CONDITIONS.
LOOK AT SAN FRANCISCO.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, THE
PRESIDENT, EMILY, SEIZING BACK
THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION AFTER
TWO LONG NIGHTS OF DEMOCRATIC
DEBATE.
>> Emily: HE DID INDEED, I
THINK IT WAS REALLY WISE THAT HE
DIDN'T NAME OF THEM BY THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NAMES.
IT REMOVED THE BALL FROM THEIR
COURT.
IT WAS ALSO SMART FOR HIM TO
CONTINUE THIS CULTURE WHERE HE'S
DRIVING THAT WEDGE BETWEEN URBAN
AND SUBURBAN VOTERS.
AS THE DEMOCRATS RIGHT NOW ARE
PUTTING ALL THEIR POLICIES FOR
EVENT HOW MUCH MONEY THEY ARE
GOING TO PUT INTO CONTINUING TO
SOLVE OR ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS,
HE IS HIGHLIGHTING ALL THIS
MONEY THAT'S GOING TO FIX
ANYTHING, HE SHOULD BE CAREFUL
NOT TO ALIENATE THE SUBURBAN
VOTERS THAT IDENTIFY WITH THE
CITIES THEY LIVE NEAR.
>> Dana: IS INTERESTING
BECAUSE OF THE PRESIDENT BRINGS
IT UP, THE MEDIA WILL TALK ABOUT
IT.
>> Greg: OF COURSE, THAT'S WHY
THEY SHOULD BE THANKING HIM
BECAUSE HE IS SHINING A LIGHT ON
A PROBLEM THAT'S BEEN AROUND FOR
DECADES.
IF YOU LOOK AT ANY DEVASTATED
CITY CHANCES ARE YOU WILL SEE
THE DEMOCRAT MACHINERY BEHIND
IT.
THE BIG LOSER FROM LAST NIGHT
WAS CNN BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
CHANCE.
AND THEY WERE -- YOU COULD TELL
HOW CRESTFALLEN THEY WERE WHEN
NO CHANCE SHOWED UP BECAUSE
WHAT'S GOING TO BE THEIR PRIME
TIME LINEUP?
WHAT IS DON LEMON GOING TO
REPORT ON?
HE MIGHT HAVE TO DO THE NEWS.
I THINK OF A CONTRAST IS THE
RALLY AND THE DEBATE, SO YOU'RE
WITNESSING THIS POSITIVE ENERGY
WHICH WAS ACTUALLY DERIVED FROM
REAL DATA.
YOU CAN'T BE HAPPY IF THE
ECONOMY SUCKS SO YOU ARE SEEING
THIS RALLY AND EVERYBODY'S
HAVING A GOOD TIME, YOU LOOK UP
AT THE STAGE AND IT'S A DOOMSDAY
CULT.
ON ONE SIDE YOU HAVE HAPPY FEET,
ON THE OTHER SIDE YOU HAVE
SOYLENT GREEN AND ONE OF THEM IS
A DELUSION AND THE DATA BACKS UP
ONE SIDE, THE OTHER SIDE, IT'S
OUR FEELING, DATA VERSES ARE
FEELING.
>> Dana: IT WASN'T JUST THE
DEBATES, IT CARRIED INTO -- YOU
HAD DEMOCRATIC LEANING GUESTS
WRITING ARTICLES OR TWEETS OR
BEING ON-AIR, SAYING -- HE
WATCHED THE DEBATES AND HE FELT
LIKE BASICALLY THEY WERE SETTING
UP PRESIDENT TRUMP TO WIN AND
NOT DOING A GOOD ENOUGH JOB FOR
THEMSELVES.
SAYING THE DEMOCRATS PUT THEIR
WORST FACE FORWARD, HOW DO YOU
THINK THE DEBATES WENT?
>> >> Capri: I KNOW THIS IS A
TOPIC WE WILL PROBABLY TOUCH
UPON TIME AND TIME AGAIN BUT AS
A DEMOCRAT IT WAS INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING, PROBABLY NO
SURPRISE TO ANYONE AROUND THIS
TABLE THAT TUESDAY NIGHT WAS
MORE MY CUP OF TEA THAN THE
WEDNESDAY EVENING, THEY WERE
ACTUALLY -- THERE WAS AT LEAST
SOME CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE
IDEALIST AND THE PRAGMATISTS, AS
OPPOSED TO DEMOCRATS GOING AFTER
ONE ANOTHER ON WEDNESDAY EVENING
WHICH JUST --
>> Emily: I WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE QUESTION ABOUT INNER CITIES,
I TOOK A LOOK AT THIS, ONLY 30
OF THOSE CITIES ACTUALLY HAVE
REPUBLICAN MAYORS AS OF THE
QUESTION IS, IS THIS AN ISSUE OF
CORRELATION OR CAUSALITY, WITH
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT THERE ARE VAGUE
CITIES THAT ARE FAILING BUT
THERE ARE ALSO RURAL AREAS
LAGGING, FROM LIFE EXPECTANCY
AND EVERYTHING ELSE AND AS
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTED A RURAL
AREA, DEMOCRATS WHO PAID ANY
ATTENTION TO RURAL COMMUNITIES,
THEY ARE SO FORGOTTEN, SO MANY
PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT IF WE JUST
PAID ATTENTION TO THEM --
>> Dana: CONSERVATIVES ALSO
SAY, IF WE COULD JUST PAY LITTLE
ATTENTION ATTENTION TO THE URBAN
AREAS, IF YOU HAVE BOTH PARTIES
WORKING TOGETHER, IF YOU HAVE
ONE PARTY RULING EITHER WAY IT
DOESN'T WORK.
>> Greg: IT WILL BE GOOD IF
BOTH PARTIES IGNORED BRIAN.
>> Brian: YEAH, I GO FOR THE
INDEPENDENTS, I GO FOR THEM.
A COUPLE THINGS.
EMILY, WHAT YOU SAID IS RIGHT,
WHEN THE PRESIDENT GOES AHEAD,
LOOK WHO'S IN CHARGE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO GO TO THE
NEXT STEP.
HERE THEY ARE PRODUCING RESULTS.
BEN CARSON IS DOING A LOT OF
GREAT THINGS, BEN CARSON OVER
THE LAST THREE DAYS WILL HAVE
HIS FINEST WEEK AS HS    HSS SEC
HIS FINEST WEEK AS HS    HSS SEE
HIS FINEST WEEK AS HS    HSS SEA
HIS FINEST WEEK AS HS    HSS SE
SECRETARY.
LET ME IN CHARGE OF BALTIMORE, I
SEE THE POTENTIAL IN THE URBAN
AREAS.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
FOCUS ON ELIZABETH WARREN, THE
DEMOCRATS WITHOUT THE SCANDAL OF
HER HERITAGE WAS BEHIND HER, HE
WAS REMINDING EVERYBODY ABOUT
IT.
>> Greg: THAT HIS "FREE BIRD,"
HE'S ALWAYS WENT TO PLAY THE
HITS AND IT WORKS.
CAN I JUST SAY SOMETHING
TANGENTIAL, A$AP ROCKY COMING
BACK TO THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S AN INTERESTING STORY WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON.
HE WATCHED THE VIDEO, CALLED THE
HEAD OF SWEDEN, THE NEXT THING
YOU KNOW HE'S HEADING HOME.
KIM KARDASHIAN PICKED UP THE
PHONE AND TALK TO HIM AND HERE'S
THE THING ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
PEOPLE TO GET TO KNOW HIM
UNDERSTAND, AND PROBABLY DIDN'T
MAKE IT CLEAR LAST NIGHT, PEOPLE
WHO DIDN'T KNOW HIM SAY FOR SURE
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT HIM
THAT'S RACIST.
SOMETIMES HE CAN BE RACIALLY
INSENSITIVE AS TIM SCOTT POINTED
OUT.
HE'S A PERSON IN TROUBLE, HE
DOESN'T SEE A BLACK PERSON IN
TROUBLE AND THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
HE WENT AFTER ELIJAH CUMMINGS
BECAUSE LEISURE
ELIJAH CUMMINGS WENT AFTER
KEVIN.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE HAVE TROUBLE
UNDERSTANDING'S.
YOU DON'T HURT HIS FEELINGS
BECAUSE HE KNOWS HE'S NOT A
RACIST.
>> Capri: HOW I THINK
ELIZABETH WARREN WILL FRAME IT,
HE'S AFRAID.
EVERY TIME YOU GET A NICKNAME
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP IT MEANS
YOU GET SOME STREET CREDIBILITY,
YOU'RE GOING TO GO OUT ON
FUND-RAISER ON IT.
IF HE'S RESURRECTING POCAHONTAS
AS HIS "FREE BIRD," IT PLAYS
INTO ELIZABETH WARREN'S HAND.
I SUGGEST HE LAY OFF.
>> Dana: DO YOU WANT TO MAKE A
REFERENCE FOR ME GO TO BREAK?
>> Emily: IT WAS JUST LIKE I
WAS AT THE CONCERT THE OTHER
NIGHT, I AGREE, HOWEVER, THE
PRESIDENT'S PRESIDENT OF
EVERYONE AND SO IT GOES AGAINST
THE NARRATIVE THAT A LOT OF THE
LEFT HAVE CLUNG TO, THAT HE'S A
RACIST NO MATTER WHAT BUT THIS
EXAMPLE WILL SERVE ONLY
POTENTIALLY TO THOSE ON THE
FENCE OR OPEN TO RATIONAL REASO
REASON.
>> Greg: I ONLY HOPE THAT
BRIAN KILMEADE EVER GETS STUCK
IN A FOREIGN JAIL,